identify complementary and supplementary
angles in the image below so just as a
reminder complementary angles are two
angles that add up to 90 degrees and
supplementary angles supplementary
angles add up to 180 degrees so let's
look at this diagram first let's look
for the complementary complementary
angles so angles that add up to 90
degrees and so they drew this right
angle right over here so we know that
angle f a h is a right angle because
they did this little half box right over
there and it's made up of two adjacent
angles and these two adjacent angles
make up a 90 degree angle so they must
add up to 90 degrees so the two angles
angle
f a c
angle
f
a c
and angle c a h
and angle c a h let me do that in a
different color since i already used
that
and angle cah
and angle c a h
are complementary because the measures
of these two angles must add up to 180
degrees or sorry must add up to this 90
degrees right over here and i think
that's all the complementary angles just
these two they add up to this right
angle to this 90 degrees now let's think
about the supplement the supplementary
angles
so supplementary
supplementary angles they add up to 180
degrees so you have angle
you have angle fac or we could call it
caf it's the same angle so angle c a f
and then this angle out here
and then this angle out here fab
when you they're adjacent to each other
and they clearly form a straight angle
which is 180 degrees when you add their
two measures so these two are clearly
supplementary
and angle fab
f a b
c a
c a f and f a b together definitely add
up to 180 degrees so they're
supplementary and then the other one we
could do angle cah
angle c
a h
which is this right over here that plus
h a b
clearly add up they form they're
adjacent they form a straight angle
so they're clearly adding up to 180
degrees so they are also supplementary
cah and
angle
h
a
b and we're done these two angles add up
to 90 these two add up to 180 these two
add up to 180.